the moderator for tan and organizer of
today's rich forum richly interesting
forum is Laura Lee Joon who is the
program manager for the Center for
future civic media and it's my pleasure
to introduce her now hi folks welcome
everybody and thanks for coming to our
session on civic media and the law today
here at the Center for future Civic
Media one of our main focuses is to
create technical and social systems to
help communities communicate better and
that we want them to organize and share
and act on information but we know that
the process of organizing sharing and
acting on information it takes a lot of
different forms and as citizens we use
media to you know help us find the local
supermarket or to drive voters to the
polls or to help share ideas online but
what happens when citizens use the media
in ways that invite the attention of the
law for example you know what if you're
involved in WikiLeaks the First
Amendment has always offered members of
the press some degree of protection
under the law in in terms of what they
do what they write about but what
happens when ordinary citizens commit
acts of journalism and how does the law
impact these acts so that's what we'll
be exploring today in in our session and
we'll be looking at federal laws and
free speech and blogging and government
transparency and all that good stuff so
our speakers today we have David ardea
who is a fellow at Harvard's Berkman
Center and he's also the director of the
citizen media law project and this
project provides legal education and
assistance and resources for people
involved in online journalism and civic
media we have Daniel Schumann who's the
policy counsel at the sunlight
foundation and at the sunlight
foundation he develops policies that
further sunlights mission of catalyzing
greater government openness and
transparency he's also the director of
sunlights Advisory Committee on
transparency and this committee works
with a coalition
of organizations to provide political
advice to the Congressional transparency
caucus and finally our moderator is and
discussion leader is Mika Siffer II and
Mika is the co-founder and editor of the
personal democracy forum and which is
both a website and an annual conference
that covers the ways technology is
changing politics Mika also runs tech
president calm which is pdfs group blog
on how politicians are using the web and
he also as a consultant focuses on how
political organizations and campaigns
and nonprofits and media entities can
adapt and thrive in the networked world
so with one little bit of logistics is
when we do take questions we will be
using the microphones so we will be
passing them around so if you have a
question we just ask you to wait and we
will run a microphone over to you so
without further ado I hand it over to
make it Thank You Lori the Sun so we're
going to try and make this as
conversational as possible it's a
relatively intimate group here and and
our goal is not to speak at you but to
talk with you and I think we're really
blessed to have a wealth of expertise
here and and knowledge to share but I
suspect there's also knowledge and
expertise in the room and given that
where we're living at a time when many
many more people are jumping in and
deciding that they too want to
participate in creating media that in
some way in pigeons on the Civic
conversation we are all in uncharted
waters together and I think that there
are there are mines in those waters that
we need to know about there are
obstacles to stick with my mangled
metaphor there there's some shallow
reefs that you don't want to run a
ground against and there's probably
blockages that that need to be opened up
in in terms of access to information
that matters
and so we're going to begin on all those
subjects before I sort of asked each of
our speakers to sort of make some
opening remarks I just wanted to ask
people who are here in the room how many
of you are in some form today
participating in creating your own media
and publishing it just a show of hands
Wow so almost everybody in the room in
some form would you call it those who
would call themselves a blogger again
almost all and those of you who didn't
raise your hand on the second question
but did on the first what would you call
yourself just call it out a journalist
okay a photographer podcaster of course
content creator okay and a sharer of
field notes all right well these are all
its that's good it's a topiary of the
the different types of content and media
makers I actually before we were getting
started was looking for what the right
shorthand where it is I don't think
blogger really encompasses it I think
the idea that anybody can commit an act
of journalism also doesn't quite
encompass it because I think we do think
of journalism as a certain kind of
message or meaning making that that may
not be what somebody who takes a picture
and post it online thinks they're doing
this or somebody who just blogs about
something personal so we're going to get
into that but I i think that the hope
today is to move into a conversational
mode and and get your your questions and
comments and and and not just hear us
pontificate but we have to allow a
little time for for that and I think
what's interesting about the two folks
that we have is that David's work as a
lawyer and
advocate for advising both journalists
new and old and and citizen journalists
if you will about the their rights and
under the law as they go about
publishing online he I think can be a
bit more of a guide for us about you
know where the law is strong and where
the law may be weak and with Daniel
coming from sunlight I'm hoping that
he'll talk to us a bit about where the
obstacles are around the information
that citizens want to get their hands on
and make meaning out of and so the two
of them complement I think very nicely
on this discussion I thought we'd start
with with David and you know if you just
give us an overview of I guess the the
major features of the law that pertain
to people publishing online and where
they need to be careful where they have
safe harbor sure Thank You Megan so when
we were talking a little bit about the
legal environment facing folks who
engage in online publishing just just
prior to the start of the panel we all a
meant it largely how Congress doesn't
understand technology how Congress
doesn't understand media and how that
tends to not help and often hurt the
situation but there's actually one
instance where Congress largely
inadvertently did a pretty good job and
I think fostering the kind of open
platforms for speech that we all enjoy
today and that is a part of the
Communications Decency Act which was
passed an a-bomb nimbus
telecommunications reform package of in
1996 that included a very small
provision that was meant to foster sites
that wish to clean up user comments and
and and the reason why it was so
important is you have to look at how the
law approached publishing prior to the
internet and that is it really saw two
major categories of folks who can be
liable for for passing on defamatory
statements and other
tortious material and that's at
publisher versus a distributor and then
in the pre-internet world publishers
like newspapers we're responsible for
every single thing in their pages that
meant a letter to the editor that they
ran if it turned out that that letter
defamed a neighbor the newspaper stepped
into the shoes of the person who wrote
the letter the publisher that's a book
publisher as well but then the other
category is a category of distributor
that's the newsstand the library and if
you if the law were to hold them just as
responsible as a publisher then
libraries would have to read every book
newsstands would have to read every
publication and they probably wouldn't
do that so they wouldn't make those
available so the law really saw this
important distinction between publisher
and distributor so as you can imagine
when the very first web sites came into
play in one of the earliest many of us
are probably familiar with you
serve in the late 90s was sued because
it had a forum called rumor ville which
is the first lesson is don't call your
forum room Ervil because all that's
going to do is generate the kind of
stuff that likely gets gets lawyers in
action and they were sued and they said
no we're a distributor you should look
at us like a library not like a
publisher and we shouldn't be
responsible for the material we didn't
create it and the court said I agree
okay we're not going to we're not gonna
hold you liable and four years later
prodigy which was a service developed by
sears I think at the time it would fell
the self elbows held itself out as a
family friendly network and it attempted
to moderate and clean up the content on
the site and said you know we're special
you come to us it's all going to be good
family wholesome stuff and and another
piece of content made it up on one of
its forms it was sued over and it said
well we should be a distributor just
like prodigy don't hold us responsible
for it and the courts because you held
yourself out to to keep a clean site
you're going to be responsible for the
content and and you're going to have
liability so immediately you can see
what the repercussions would be of that
that is that you do absolutely nothing
and you're probably not going to face
liability but if you do anything to
improve your site you're going to
potentially face liability that's really
a counter incentive and Congress stepped
in in 1996 and included this little
provision as part of an effort to stop
harmful materials from getting to minors
and one of the things they thought was
if we give website operators like
CompuServe and prodigy the ability to
clean up stuff on their site and let's
say some stuff slips through that their
know that we're not going to hold them
liable just because some bad stuff slips
through and that provision survived when
the entire rest of the statute got
struck down as unconstitutional on a
case that lawyers love to talk about a
Reno V ACLU that actually that case was
filed before the statute even went into
effect the rest of the communication
agency act it was in joined and then
struck down and the only part that lived
on was a section 230 and most lawyers
who do work in the internet space would
say that this this protection for
website operators who allow others to
use their site to speak out to upload
information that the fact that they're
not going to be held liable for that
material was what created allowed things
like YouTube and blogging services and
many of the sites that you run those of
you raised your hand and blog and you
allow users to publish on your site
would you do that if somebody were to
post a comment on your site get that
turn out be defamatory very unlikely you
would do that the reason that you're
able to do that is because of this
statute which for for all intents and
purposes shielded shields you from
liability for any material that's
submitted by your users it doesn't
protect against against copyright claims
which is governed under a separate
statute called the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act and that that protection
is granted to you only if you do certain
things and one of the things you have to
do which a lot of people find very
strange is you have to download a PDF
off of the Library of Congress's website
fill it out by hand send it back into
them with 105 dollar check designating
someone from your website to receive
notices when there's copyright
infringement this is called a agent the
copyright notification agent and once
you do that with
with regard to the to the Copyright
Office you then will not have liability
if someone were to upload some copyright
infringing material to your site and
another the copyright holder complains
about it your obligation is only to take
it down notify the user that you've
received this complaint and then if the
user believes that they have say a fair
use right to have the information then
they notify you I you can then put them
information back up you're free and
clear and the copyright holder needs to
sue the user those two protections are
very different than what exists in the
offline world and when I talk to
journalists who work still in the print
business they they just can't believe
that it's a different regime it's a
different set of legal requirements it
is it's it's a conscious decision on
Congress to give the online space some
breathing room and Congress I think did
pretty well certainly with the CDA the
Communications Decency Act with regard
to the copyright stuff a lot of material
gets taken down as a result of specious
claims of copyright infringement you see
that happen every day on youtube so
there are some folks who believe that
that might not be the best result but
from the website operators perspective
those two protections are really
important so very quick follow-up just
to cover the lay of the land you don't
want to leave the audience with the
impression that a online publisher is
protected from liability for potential
libel or invasion of privacy I mean they
still other aspects of the laws still
apply right absolutely so so the person
who creates the content is still
responsible for that neither of these
statutes changes that at all so if
you're writing your own blog posts if
you're producing the information on your
own you still face all of the range of
legal liability that any publisher faces
that includes defamation privacy
copyright trademark and other forms of
criminal and civil liability this only
applies these two statutes I mentions
only apply in the context when it's a
third party when it's not you doing the
creation someone else is using your
website your online service to do that
ok ok so we're laying some groundwork
down
Daniel so we're we're in the early ages
of a an age of mass participation in
using information creating and sharing
and also taking advantage of existing
official information if you will to make
meaning of the world around us what do
you see as as both the potential in the
obstacles at work now in terms of people
who want to do something with government
information is it a clear playing field
or are do we face problems thanks so
there's I hate to hearken back to your
topiary metaphor but in the you know in
the garden there are snakes and there
are rocks and there are all sorts of
debris that's in the way of people using
government information now there is my
apologize folks there is a gardener on
the watch you know and there have been
efforts both within the executive and
legislative branch to try to sorry folks
clear away some of the shrubbery in the
underbrush but there's a lot more to do
so in in terms of positive efforts what
we've seen with the current
administration is the issuance of the
open government directive which has been
an effort to make more public
information available online agencies
that were under the under the authority
of the president were required to make
three high-value data sets whatever
high-value means available online and to
undergo a whole system of actions in
terms of how they make information
available so they had to put on their
website you know if it's department of
justice doj gov / open and on that site
they would report on fulfilling FOIA
requests and they would report on
communications that were going between
the agency and in the Congress and a
bunch of other information that's pretty
useful it also required the president
had created data of a required a lot of
information we put on data of a lot of
database information which continues to
be filled out through several hundred
thousand data sets on there now although
most of them are map information in the
same time the Congress is trying to get
in the act a bit as well both in the
house and the Senate there was the
public online Information Act which was
introduced which would do three major
things one it would talk about data
standards it would create a body that
would try to figure out how do you make
information available for people to use
if you you know if you put up a PDF of
you know a giant data said it's not
particularly helpful you can't really
play with it you can't really use it but
if you make it available and sort of you
know slightly more sophisticated data
format that structured in certain kinds
of ways then people can start playing
with it that you know makes it a lot
more useful a lot more helpful to people
who want to interact with the
information to mash it up and use it in
different kinds of ways it also did
something which the government is not
good at doing it all and it would have
required the different branches of
government to actually talk to one
another would have gotten the executive
the legislative in the judicial branch
in the same place at the same time to
try to figure out not rules but sort of
principles to govern how they make
information available these two things
would be very helpful in as sort of a
third piece was sort of the hammer to
the nail which is if there was
information that was supposed to be
publicly available and this would have
changed the presumption so that most
information would have to be publicly
available if it's not online would have
given citizens a private right to sue to
encourage that the information be made
available online in the in the lawsuit
mechanism was similar to that under FOIA
now I don't know if you've noticed but
there was an election recently so
Congress is changing hands at least the
houses and what that means for all this
legislation is that will have to be
reintroduced is going to be new
priorities what we have seen is both
with Democrats and Republicans both in
the executive and the legislative branch
there is a great desire among many to
push for transparency legislation so we
will see what happens so so let's go to
some of the roadblocks and I'll run
through these anecdotally and quickly
since I think we have a lot that we wish
to chat about so let's say that you're
interested in congressional ethics
Information legislation you know there's
rules in the house and the Senate about
this information needs to be made
available to the public this is one of
the great reforms that came about so how
would you go about and get it well there
is a room in the basement of the Canon
building the Canon building is in
Capitol Hill Capital Hill of courses in
Washington DC you have to go there
request a certain subset of 19 documents
that we have identified having to do
with personal financial disclosures
conflicts of interests all these kinds
of things and you can go and review them
which is you know pretty helpful but you
have to go to Washington you have to go
to this particular room between nine and
five monday to friday during of course
regular business hours you can't email
it to yourself because the computers on
which these databases reside are not
connected to the internet you can burn
it onto a CD because they don't have a
cd-rom drive connected you can stick
your thumb drive in there because
they've glued in the ports the only way
to access this information is to take it
print it out at a ten cents a page for
thousands and thousands of pages of
information if you're interested in
reviewing it and of course if you want
to make use of it well so you just have
to go and hire someone to go rekey and
all the data they already have in a
database so that you can make use of it
this is public information not available
online non useful formats and it's
really really difficult to get your
hands on it and even when information is
made available online it's often not
done so in a very useful kind of way so
let's talk about earmarks those have
been in the news a lot there have been
several efforts over the last couple
years to restrict the use of earmarks or
to make more information available about
how they work this came about through
2007 law known as the Honest Leadership
and open government act and what it
required among other things that in the
later rules change was that each member
of Congress is required to put their
earmarks requests on their website each
member puts it on their own website now
if you want to go and actually find it
good luck we actually undertook the the
effort to go and look at all 435 House
websites
to look for this information we found it
in most of them it's really hard they're
under misleading names oftentimes in
PDFs if you want to actually analyze the
information it's really hard to do folks
over at Washington watch undertook the
effort they had a huge crowd source
effort where people including myself
went through and hand entered all the
data so you could start figuring out who
gets what air mark and for how much and
how does it work now there is a database
that exists both in the house and senate
that has all this information but we
can't get our hands on it its internal
to the appropriations committees and we
have so far been unsuccessful and
convinced them to make it available now
there is legislation pending to do this
in fact I think there are about 50 bills
that are pending to make these databases
publicly available the most notable one
in the Senate is sponsored by Senator
Coburn it's known as the earmark
transparency Act and it would basically
make these databases available publicly
online so you could sort it sort it
search it mash it up make all sorts of
interesting use of these kinds of
information and it went put it up in
PDFs which of course are difficult to
use but in some sort of a rich data
format so this is what's this is what
our government is doing sometimes
they're helping with data of sometimes
they're taking away with earmarks and
let me give just one more quick example
that I that I particularly enjoy I was
interested in information about tarp
which is the wall street bailout and the
government makes available a whole bunch
of PDFs that has all basically were all
of the 787 billion dollars I think
that's the right amount has been has
been yeah they're not sure either where
that money maybe it's 877 billion it's
it's it's a lot of money we're all this
money is being spent so they make it
available in PDFs but they've also made
available a database the database is
fantastic searchable sortable sortable
downloadable but they add a license
provision that when you download it they
have to retain control so if you use it
you have to cite them just fine i'm
happy to cite them but they also say
they are willing to change the terms of
service so at some point in the future
they could say you know it's been
wonderful that you've had this stuff but
we don't think you should be able to use
it that way or they want to change how
you can act
sit and they can simply pull it back now
with this be upheld by a court of law I
don't know I'm not an expert in that in
that realm but I do know that this is an
impediment to people out there who want
to use this information to talk about
what's going on citizen bloggers run
into all sorts of problems you can't
reuse video from house committees
because of its copyrighted by c-span you
can you know use this type information
there's whole sets of data that's
incredibly helpful that are available in
some kind of way but not in the ways
that really leave it open free and clear
for people to use without concerns about
the government coming and knocking on
their door and so with that I think
that's a pretty good introduction to
some of the barriers that are faced by
citizen journalists I'm happy to talk
about this more so I have a question for
both of you which is the and first to
David really how much is how many
collisions are happening between the
citizen journalists of the world in the
u.s. especially and the law I mean
you're you're at Berkman you know you've
set up a program that provides a lot of
free legal advice to people and how much
of this is people who are actually in
the middle of fighting you know some
authority that is going after them
versus people just looking for advice
and is there any kind of chilling effect
going on what do you see happening in
terms of the space right now well your
last point by the chilling effect is the
most concerning think is what we see is
really just a tip of the iceberg when
folks come to us and ask for legal help
because they're they've received a
lawsuit or a threatening letter there
are probably tens if not hundreds more
who don't come to us or don't come to
anyone they don't post it on their blog
they just take the information down and
they and they go away because they can't
afford to lose their house and and so we
see a growing number of these they
increase they've been increasing every
year I'd say relative to the proportion
of blogs that are out there and websites
that are out there it's a very small
percentage but if you're the one who
receives it doesn't matter if
you're in a very small percentage it's
still a legal threat and potentially can
involve a lot of money because the other
problem that in the United States we
have a system where generally speaking
even if you win your case as a defendant
you're not going to get your legal fees
back you're going to be out of pocket
even if the case really had no
likelihood of success in the first place
and it gets dismissed at a very early
stage just the fact of going out and
getting a lawyer can be expensive so we
try to help with that by having lawyers
who are interested in doing this work
for free but there aren't enough lawyers
out there to help everybody and not
everybody comes asking for that help so
the chilling effect is is I think far
more extensive than any research that's
that's been directed at this question
and there's been very little research
directed at this question and I think
one of the things as we as lawyers need
to think about and those in the room I
would ask as well is that in the past we
had very substantial institutions doing
some of this government accountability
work the New York Times The Washington
Post could stand up to a threat namine
they could publish information that the
government claimed violated national
security with the expectation that
they'd have the very best lawyers right
there ready to fight for them and they
could afford to have that fight
WikiLeaks does it by having their
director stay out of the country and fly
all around the world and servers all
over the world so that no single
government can stop that that's their
model that's also a fairly expensive and
intensive model but for those of you out
there who let's say you run one site and
you discover some information that let's
say is shows government corruption or
doesn't show or somehow ports powerful
institution in our society on the
defensive you run the real risk of
having them lawyer up come after you and
put you in a position where you can't
afford to stand up for your rights and
that's a big concern Daniel on the in in
terms of what you see in Washington are
there cases where citizen journalists
are also being hindered I mean not just
by the the data itself being tucked away
in some room where you
have to make an appointment but whether
it's legal practice or common practice I
mean I there's one in particular that
always bothers me which is the whole
issue of credentialing that's an easy
one but now I have to so so so the
actually the question of credentialing
is a very good one when you look at how
the House and Senate press galleries are
set up they recognize two types of media
print and television well that leaves
out of course a whole bunch of folks and
of course print and television have a
very great incentive of keeping out the
great unwashed masses which of course is
the rest of us they haven't changed the
rules regarding who gets access to the
the committee video feeds for example or
the the feeds from the house or the
feeds from the Senate and in quite a
long time those rules haven't changed
since 1994 I believe or 95 the last time
the republicans took over the house and
if you want to go and cover a hearing
it's just about impossible you do it
basically at the at the pleasure of the
committee and you have to apply ahead of
time and of course if they don't like
you or if you're affiliated with the
other side or a whole other series of
reasons they can simply lock the doors
on you and this does happen this doesn't
just happen to journalists they also do
this occasionally to people who want a
video tape actually from the other side
of the aisle which is sort of funny that
they would do it to their own members so
they are there are there are a number of
examples along these lines where people
who are you know members of the Civic
Media simply can't get in the door one
sort of positive aspect is that at least
for now with the changeover in the house
there does seem to be an appetite to
reexamine the house rules sunlight
issued a series i think was 78 or 80
recommendations to change the house
rules I had a very fun time reading
through all 70 or 80 pages of them to
come up with those recommendations that
include changing changing so that
bloggers or people who are recognized in
certain kinds of ways
can participate there are sort of other
pieces to this as well so I mean we're
talking about it from a credentialing
point of view but there's also how do
you get access to the the video feeds
themselves is it we're talking about
this a bit before is to filter through
c-span which owns the copyright or is it
is it in some other way restricted from
people being able to reuse it and to
mash it up in things along those lines
problems that I hate it's not mainstream
media but but maybe traditional media I
guess is probably a better phrase that
traditional media simply don't run into
you know oftentimes hearings will simply
not be covered for a lack of interest by
c-span or the major networks but there
are many other people who would be more
than happy to do so but they simply
don't have that that opportunity I mean
and just if I if I went to a committee
hearing and wanted to take pictures I'm
not allowed to unless I have a
credential to do that yes that's correct
yeah okay I want to start to open things
up and you know I said we wanted to make
this as conversational as possible so I
and not that I don't have more questions
to ask but I want to give the audience
and opportunity to chime in at this
point if anybody has something that they
do want to ask or comment you want to
make so that you know we're not waiting
until the last half hour for that to
happen so does anybody want to yeah go
to a mic yeah we have a couple people
who r mics hi Mark tomizawa six degrees
of innovation a known suspect in micah's
world former journalist someone who's
exploring just what the full rights are
of an independent citizen because I
found that actually when I go and talk
to CNN folks i know i can take more
pictures on capitol hill than they can I
can take a private camera around and
shoot photos they can't so I'm actually
interested in pushing it all the way to
the end and not even calling it citizen
journalism just calling it citizen and
calling everything else conversation
witnessed conversation recorded relayed
conversation so that's all media and I'm
wondering who is when people use the
word journalism it immediately triggers
a
frame it has all kinds of rules around
it so I'm wonder if we just for a second
kind of chop off the J word what does
that then let us do as people who are
paying for c-span who are paying for
Capitol Hill who are paying for the
people who are working there I mean what
are our rights fully as citizens and
what are the rights of kids who aren't
even voters or workers and so they're
not even like a lobbyist you know I'm
just looking at a variety of ways in
which people can re-engage rather than
participate in civic engagement which
seems to have a whole lot of rules up
front and just saying well what rights
do we have served natural rights and the
other small piece is fair use in light
of all that fair use is transformative
that's the measure and I know the people
at Temple and the people American
University we're working on that so if
you take the concept of citizen fair use
stuff we've paid for where might that
get us because it might be some
interesting tests if people knew what
should be tested so so mark you were
asking about sort of rights of access
and one thing that's interesting about
the way the Supreme Court has looked at
rights of access when the press has
brought these cases is it said that the
press has no additional rights the
public doesn't have and that these are
really public rights at the act that the
press is acting on behalf of the public
so for example the right to be present
during a trial during a criminal trial
or a civil trial the court has said
that's a fundamental right that's part
of the way this country was set up that
our judicial system be open into public
view and access to government property
into government activities and those
kinds of things so the court the Supreme
Court has not generally said that the
press has any special rights and as you
pointed out in fact as a citizen you may
have rights to get places that the press
may be excluded from and that really
comes up from the way a property owner
uses contract law to limit access to the
property so you know if you were to look
at the back of your ticket to a sporting
event it's it's got a lot of fine print
on there and one of them is is that
you're not going to take photographs and
and otherwise engage in activities that
that i'm talking about professional
sporting events many of those leagues
have sold those rights for a lot of
money to broadcast companies and we're
starting to see fights for example at
NCAA games where folks are live blogging
and they're getting sued for doing that
it's violating the contractual right
that the that the the stadium has when
it allows you in saying that through
this small print you've agreed to that
and we all had to sign little waivers to
be recorded and let our our images be
out there but we actually knew we were
doing that and that was voluntary but
when you go into a stadium and you just
want a report on what you're you know
that just tell the world what you're
doing there you don't know you've given
away that right so I'm not sure that's
consent in it and a lot of some courts
have said that it therefore may not be
enforceable so there so the law comes
into play in a lot of different ways
with regard to access and your point
about sort of that that we need to be as
expansive and possible and viewing
citizen rights I think that's exactly
right the problem is is when it comes
into play when you're in these sort of
non-governmental forums like sporting
events other public events that are on
private property or say a politician's
fundraiser yeah absolutely that's right
that's right then you and Daniel may
have something to mention there because
I'll talk about your fair use question
it wait a minute but even in the evenin
the governmental context you run into a
lot of problems if you want to go and
record the floor of the House of
Representatives you can try but they're
going to me before you go in there they
take away your cell phone and any other
electronic devices that may you may
happen have on you so trying to exercise
that right in that space is going to be
impossible there was a sort of funny
example representative culverson from
Texas had a hearing on the Supreme Court
had to do with funding for them and
Justice Breyer and Thomas attended and
Cole person has I forget what the call
there like a flip phone then I've
clipped where he took it any broadcast
Justice Thomas and he said see it's not
that hard for the Supreme Court to be
you know live online because I'm doing
that right now which didn't go over that
well
and you know if you want to record
what's going on in the courts you know
they have a supreme authority over that
that venue unless of course Congress
passes a law changing how they do things
and if you try to go into the Supreme
Court with the camera that's not going
to work out so well in fact even if you
go into private forums they're there
been a number of examples I think most
recently with Justice Scalia where
someone was trying to record the event
where he was speaking and the i guess
the Supreme Court police came around and
confiscated the equipment and erased it
now they didn't actually have a right to
do so but they did it nonetheless and
this has happened more than once so you
know and if you try to go into a member
office you know with the camera you're
going to run into security questions you
know there they'll be afraid that you
know you're trying to show a way for
someone to come in and shoot it up or
something on those lines so you know as
a practical met you know there's a legal
you know a legal possibility within the
First Amendment of things that you
theoretically can do but practice
unfortunately limited in ways that don't
necessarily make sense and as a private
citizen it's very very hard and very
expensive to try to push back against
that okay well we're at MIT so I have to
ask this question I mean this could be
you know one of those new pens that
records everything we're saying right
and the glasses that you're wearing I
recently saw you know we're approaching
the point where miniaturization of video
cameras can be just embedded in
somebody's glasses so isn't technology
going to up Celeste some of these rules
or do you think that they'll you no rush
to you know make you take your glasses
off before you go to a congressional
hearing so that's that's a really good
question and I don't know the answer to
it I I think that they have you know
they have sovereign ability to control
their own space and if you go and
violate the rules it's really an
interesting question of what they're
going to do to you if they can do
anything for example if you go and take
live feed of the house for and you reuse
it for some other purpose now this
Congress really going to come after you
what you know what authority do they
have what are they going to do how are
they going to see you is it going to
make them look worse by trying to do
this kind of thing then by simply
letting it letting it pass by I don't
know the answer to these questions but
it's a really interesting one the flip
side of that however is the privacy
expectations of those around you and in
that space that we law has a long way to
catch up that the most of the privacy
rights that we recognize are built on a
foundation of a reasonable expectation
of privacy which by definition is a
slippery slope and it's it changes over
time and as these technologies become
more accepted then the expectation
changes and more and more gets permitted
and that's really where we're facing now
is we're starting to realize that the
ways the law thinks about privacy don't
work they don't work in today's world
and they certainly aren't going to work
when we talk about miniaturization and
we're recording devices are naturally
part of what we wear as we wear smart
clothes with nanotechnology and it's
picked you know all of these things are
in mesh networks all of that information
is being communicated all of the
environmental variables everything is
being recorded as a default the law
really doesn't know and I think Danny
knows plane was right we don't know what
the law is going to say on that but one
thing we I know is that the law doesn't
have a very good answer for that
actually it's a good segue to a question
I wanted to ask you and then we get back
to the audience section 230 which you
started out with as the bulwark of a lot
of freedom on the web for websites to
host free-for-alls do you worry that you
know some violation of privacy I mean
I'm thinking of the auto admit case
where to I think they were yale law
school graduates or students two women
were basically bludgeoned in the
comments section of this site where lot
law students sort of freely and
anonymously talk about people and
because Google would surface those links
high up if somebody did a biographical
search on either of these people they
were you know understandably upset that
their reputations were being completely
dragged through the dirt they've sued
they've managed to uncover some of the
people who've made some of these
comments and are kind of holding a sword
over their heads the site owner i think
is still immune but is also feeling a
lot of pressure and is section 230
really that stable you know couldn't
there be a case where you know it would
it'll fall before political reasons
because someone is allowing child
pornography prostitution you know would
slavery I mean they're they're all kinds
of bad stuff online so you know are you
saying what about it's it's holding firm
it doesn't sound like Congress really
knew what it was doing from your
description and you know Congress can
get swayed very easily by these bursts
of you know popular upset I think it's
very unlikely we would see complete
repeal of the protections businesses
have been business models have been
built on this they are now powerful well
financed armed with lobbyists and so I
think you'd have a heart beyond likely
to Congress would repeal it I'm more
concerned about the sort of death
through a thousand duck bites where
little pieces are carved out and the
craigslist whether they Craigslist
killer here in Massachusetts where a
fellow used craigslist to make contact
with women that he then allegedly killed
and you know the problem is is and I'm
sure that that a lot of folks here at
MIT think about this in their work is
that when you build a tool it can be
used for good and bad does that mean
that the two lat
self is bad and I think many of us would
agree that the that there are horrible
things that are said and done through
the internet but that overall the impact
has been far more beneficial than
harmful and as we start to try to fix
the instances of bad conduct we run the
great risk of because our efforts our
own can only be law is a very blunt
instrument it's it we may be able to
correct the thing we want to but at the
cost of changing a lot of other things
that are very good in a lot of speech
that should be protected so I hope that
any efforts would keep that in mind and
that would be a kind of conversation
that's a pretty sanguine view of the way
Congress works and in many cases they
don't work that way so I do worry about
the really bad set of facts creating a
case that sort of pushes an effort to
carve out some exception and once we go
with this carve out approach I worry
that we would start to carve out lots of
different kinds you know what about
financial fraud okay well then financial
fraud gets carved out prostitution gets
carved out okay well about the fam
ettore speech that's been determined by
a court to be defamatory okay let's
carve that out before you know it we're
left with with Swiss cheese and we're
really not giving website operators we
put them back in the position where
their fear of legal liability makes them
reluctant to allow their their websites
and online platforms to be used because
you can imagine if we put liability
let's say on your ISP the entity that is
your essential for you to even connect
to the internet in the first place if we
put them in a position of being
responsible for the content they make
available to you they would use deep
packet inspection they would monitor
everything you read they're probably
doing that already but and and and they
would you know that they would they
would use all the tools available to
them which are quite extensive filtering
tools available even today to make sure
that only the things you received were
the most bunnell and least likely to
result in liability III would i would
think that would be a world we don't
want to live in and if we can keep that
in mind as we move down this road of
trying to repeal a statute that's been
so important to that
that we that we be careful okay let's
take it back to the audience yes going
to the point of going forward with the
discussion and the topic which is not
going to be covered in any way shape or
form one day or these last ten years
because it's a moving target but it's
also about technology allowing ahead of
the legislation to have to have press
explode with the one in a million bad
apple so to speak that's too that the
tendency of media and general the
national enquirer still lives that's not
good we go away there was a conference
and it's a yearly conference in New York
City it's called open video conference I
believe it would be org they have
speakers from very different silos of
interest including the monitor people
that are trying to d well to anonymize
information but so to be able to sell
trends that they that they are able to
with their tools etc so the one of the
four threads was in the main room the
auditorium that is that was videoed and
the other ones were just scattered I
don't know exactly if those videos are
up yet this was October first and second
just a few weeks ago but they had just
looking at the resources looking at the
speakers and the topics and then perhaps
you know skimming some of the video of
that one room has addressed these and
does address the pre beta versions that
are out there including the fair use and
the very beginning of thinking was
saturday cannot remember her name but
she was she was championing the
successes that are not in the press
about fair use and saying that instead
of the regulations which are
very tricky to put pinned down can it be
three minutes well if it's a six minute
song three minutes is half that song and
so it's not even defined as to how many
minutes it's it's like a minor part of
that piece of media can be used for fair
use with with good intentions and with
public intentions parody it can get away
with creativity and parody and some of
the big names even you can slip them
into some of the Big Show's radio and TV
and they are they're getting success
with that so she's saying that don't
ignore that get more of that in some of
our our information when we have these
these these um these forums do you have
a question I do about the K about the
filters Justin's last week you're
announcing how some of the ISPs finally
have been filtering for the cell phones
that are for minors anywhere from there
talk about how many cell phones well he
and others 3200 what they quoted was it
was WBZ 3200 text for one high schooler
in one month just the text and so just
even the cost is was one factor of
filtering but the actual testing of the
of these tools is there any place that
will be on going to allow for continuing
discussion and bringing to light anybody
know that somebody in an institution is
ongoing so I'm thinking it should be an
academic as opposed to business where
they're sold off and then you get what
happens with the information there is
there anybody that knows of anybody in
academia that's considering having an
ongoing discussion board blog about
these issues so filtering worldwide is a
is a very complicated topic that a lot
of organizations do pay attention to
just down the street where I work at the
Berkman Center there's a group called
the OpenNet initiative that it looks at
filtering
the world and they do reports every
month or two on a different region
instead of countries there's Center for
Democracy and technology has also been
looking at that e EF f looks at
filtering Center for Democracy and
technology CDT now that's definitely an
issue that's that's a great concern to
those of us who care about free speech
rights and I'll tie your point mark
raised it as well about fair use which
is that it's an essential doctrine
because it limits the copyright holders
ability to stop subsequent uses and the
courts have said that it's essential to
first us to the copyright law being
acceptable under the First Amendment and
so we all need to be vigilant about
making sure that we're putting forth our
for fair use rights when when we're
using the work of others and someone is
claiming that it's infringing and that
means being aware that that you can
raise that as a defense it also means
you know getting legal help rather than
taking information down if you're faced
with a cease and desist letter and it
means supporting organizations that do
work around fair use Stanford has a fair
use project that is exclusively focused
on fair use and the fair use right
because it's it's it's you know all of
us have an obligation to be vigilant
about protecting our rights we can't
rely on government to do it as Daniels
showing that they put all kinds of
impediments in our way so we each have
an individual obligation to do that and
fair use is one of those ways we can do
it other questions yeah go ahead if you
say who you are L so that's always know
I Andrew Whittaker I'm with Center for
future Civic Media so while
acknowledging that these issues are
largely at the federal level with First
Amendment questions or copyright
questions are there questions or
concerns that you have of what's
happening at state or municipal levels
particularly given that a lot of Sid say
most citizen journalism or Civic Media
happens at the town or you know
neighborhood level that's a really good
question did
so so actually the concern you know some
sunlight foundation focuses at the
federal level but the concerns at the
state and local level are as great if
not greater answer in certain
circumstances you know there are there
are stories of people for example trying
to record encounters that they have with
the police where though you know the
turn on their their iPhone and try to
record what happens and oftentimes the
results is that they get their head
bashed in where things that you would
necessarily see the federal government
is much smaller in certain way so you
wouldn't see those kinds of of instances
there's all you know there's on the
federal / there's more awareness I think
in many instances of these kinds of
issues but if you try to go to a town
hall meeting and try to record it you're
going to have a really hard time you
also don't have so federal information
is not subject federal documents are not
subject to copyright state and local
information however I believe is so that
states can control how that information
is disseminated how that information is
used in ways that the federal government
simply cannot and this is actually true
in most foreign countries as well is
that there's something called its crown
copywriter there's other terms for it as
well where you know power over the
information is retained by the locality
where they will sell it and you know if
you want to find out the local building
code it could very well be that you
can't get your hands on it or you have
to pay a fee to use it and it's going to
be the same thing for for all sorts of
different types of records you after why
and local governments have passed a
local equivalent to FOIA that works well
that there's going to be local
enforcement in the right kind of way
you're going to have much more localized
political factors that make things
harder so I think on the state level you
in local if you actually run into the
same considerations if not even more
difficult circumstances I'd second
Daniels point that it's as bad if not
worse at the local and state level when
it comes to access to government
information through these formal legal
vehicles but it's also the case that
we're starting to see a lot of
innovation and experimentation because
the government's a difficult party to
deal with you may be able to work out
deals for example app developers who get
access to bus information
and make that information available
we're seeing a lot of that crime data
the aggregation of crime data where a
local website works out a deal with its
police department to get an XML feed
assuming that the police can provide it
in that way or they get it in raw form
and they turn into something that's
usable for them that's also an area
where there's have been a lot of
experimentation and there's a group here
at MIT called extract which crowdsources
environmental harms and uses a
geographic information systems to pull
all that together into a multi-layered
map that uses all different kinds of
government sourced information to to
show us the kinds of effects that oil
and gas drilling are having around the
country so in that sense in people are
working outside the law to make
important things happen and are my job
as a lawyer is to make sure the law
doesn't get in the way of that and even
better if the law can help facilitate
that but we are seeing a lot of exciting
experimentation around the use of
technology to fill local information
needs in a way that sort of gets around
the impediments of the law what's up
it's just occurred to me I mean there
are a lot of sites that host user
reviews of products of people of
restaurants of services Yelp
ratemyprofessor.com and so on are they
just as well shielded by section 230 as
you know the more political journalists
type of political blog or have you seen
cases where you know restaurant owner
feels like they're being maligned what's
their recourse so so far they have been
shielded by section 230 no claim that
i'm aware of it's been successful
against a review site like that however
a lot of lawyers have been creative
about their arguments and for example
yelp has faced several claims where the
party bringing the suit has alleged that
Yelp offered to create positive ratings
for them if they paid for that and
essentially almost like an extortion
type claim
in the cases where that's been raised
there's been no evidence to demonstrate
that and the courts have been dismissing
those but so there could be situations
where a review site can get it lose its
protections by engaging in some sort of
activities that that a court would find
take it outside of their protections now
the interesting thing so the hotels have
been really unhappy about this lately
and I just ready yeah the bedbug stuff
is well but I just read a great article
on Slate not written not written by a
lawyer but it was talking about how that
those hotels that have embraced consumer
reviews especially through tripadvisor
are doing fantastically well these are
small non chain hotels they wouldn't
otherwise be able to get folks because
they're not the West End there at the
Hyatt nobody heard about him people are
going on tripadvisor they're seeing that
they're high ranked and they have people
monitoring these complaints so when
someone complains that the light bulbs
out some but you know on they see that
they tweet it someone responds from the
hotel because they're monitoring it and
they get somewhere up then they fix it
if they get a bad review on tripadvisor
they address the problem and they talk
about it and they let they don't go and
Sue about it they engage through the
same channels that the complainant was
using and as a result they're finding
that they're doing much much better
taking that approach then you know I'm
going to sue you and force you to take
it down and I think as we move more
towards folks rail up realizing that
this is empowering to consumers in the
past if you had a bad experience at a
hotel you could write a letter to your
editor and hope they put it in there but
you're like I told you the newspaper
would be liable if it was defamation and
they're probably not going to run it now
you can post it on yelp you can post it
on tripadvisor and feel like you know
you've had a cathartic experience by
getting it off your chest others can
benefit from reading that and perhaps
the hotel can read it and do something
about it and so I think there are better
ways to look at it than just how can
hotels that get bad reviews or
restaurants to get bad reviews get them
taken down to me that's the wrong
perspective to have ok well then we'll
come to you in a sec a follow on to that
though so the Federal Trade Commission
recently decided that it needed to get
into the business
of warning bloggers about potentially
needing to reveal if they're making a
product endorsement if they have some
sort of financial relationship with the
company that makes the product so how do
you advise people in that space because
I totally agree with you this is
empowering consumers but has the FTC
created a new potential mind that people
might not even realize they could be
stepping on what are their affirmative
things that you have to do if you write
about products on your website uh you
know you happen to blog about cameras
because you're you know that's your
hobby is the F it has the FTC sort of
intruded here or is it what's your read
on how that's playing out so I think
Mick is referring to last year the FTC
issued guidelines for bloggers and other
users of social media that that receives
some financial compensation as a result
of a product endorsement so if you can
and send you a camera for free and then
you write about it positively on your
blog the FTC would see that as a problem
now the FTC has said that they will not
that they will not seek financial
penalty from the bloggers they would
simply send a letter and say that you
violate it and they would actually go
after cannon to do it then and these
guidelines were released last year the
FTC says it's not a change in policy
it's just a clarification of policy that
that this is sort of what they call
unfair trade practices they've always
had jurisdiction over it the only one
entity in the year they've gone after is
Ann Taylor the clothing manufacturer for
giving away gift cards to a bunch of
bloggers and then not those bloggers
didn't disclose it they did not go after
the bloggers themselves so I generally
advise people that that if they're in
gay if they're engaging in product
reviews and they're receiving some kind
of compensation whether it's a free
product or some other benefit that they
be transparent about it which is you
know one of the fundamental values of
journalism is to transparency and so
that actually I think improves the
quality of the information they're
providing to their readers by saying I
got the product for free I still liked
it or I didn't like it but to be
transparent about it and it left you see
going about it because what they're
concerned about is astroturf thing this
you know where a company spends a lot of
money to get a lot of people to pretend
like they're users of the product and to
use social media to to flout it in in
their view that distorts the the
marketplace the amount of information
that's available so that's what they're
trying to address I think that's a
laudable objective of course the Devils
in the details and so far they haven't
gone after individual bloggers or social
media users there's actually there's a
sort of a flip side to that as well and
there was just an article on this
recently not astroturfing but aster
tweeting or where you know of course
corporations go on or whoever it is
who's selling something and they you
know they go on to your blog they
participate in the bog and the or the
review on Yelp and they say this is a
great product or they say hey this
politician is really interesting you
should go to his website and there was
recent discovery that 50,000 links to
the GOP website from a bunch of fake a
bunch of fake fake folks on Twitter and
the question the question is and this
happens on both sides but the question
is you know you know we're talking about
mine fields for people trying to run
these kinds of fora what you know what
obligation do you have to go through and
say this person is real and this person
is fake from a legal point of view I
don't think you have much of one at all
but certainly as you're trying to do
these kinds of things trying to run a
well you know well-functioning site you
you know do you want to force people to
disclose their identities you know how
do you you know are you going to set
rules for how people engage with the
folks that you're trying to engage with
there's all sorts of things that are
wrapped up here they're very complicated
of a question here yeah i'm james miller
also with the center i have to request
to make but before i do what the FTC
intervention is really interesting I
didn't know about this here's a rough
analogy in the old days if a
professional journalist was a travel
writer and she had her hotel room paid
for by the hotel or the airline gave the
newspaper or the tickets to go to the
place and write the story about
traveling
that was not a legal issue it was
considered to be ethical and for a long
time it wasn't even that it was just the
way you did business so what's causing
the shift would be an interesting
question asked I've an answer for that
one I just lazy arse otherwise I'll
forget what I have to ask you the second
thing I'd like to raise is actually a
follow-up to Andrews comments having to
do with jurisdiction and it also takes
us back to the earlier question about
who is and who is not a journalist and
that's about shield laws which are only
a state phenomenon and kind of uneven at
that although there was a an attempt the
closest attempt yet to make it a federal
law so what are they do they work are
they worth pursuing either any for the
old media or for the new and then I had
another question which I really have
forgotten maybe it'll come back probably
not but I'll hold on to the microphone
anyway okay shield laws is a very good
question yeah so first on the FTC part
is the FTC issued clarifications two or
three months ago to address this very
question and what they said is that all
those old institutions actually have
procedures in place to make disclosure
if they felt it was necessary number one
and number two that readers of the you
know a travel section newspaper assumed
that the journalist was getting it for
free I actually disagree with that but
that was the FTC said why they're
treating social and online media
differently than in the print world so
shield laws I think they're very
important and you're right we do not
have a federal shield law we've got I
think 26 or 27 states or so that have
them and they could be very important
but many of them were drafted with a
different media environment and they
don't always map well to online media
some have very narrow definitions of
who's covered some are use institutional
definitions and that's been the versus a
functional definition is it what you do
that would qualify you or is it who you
work for that qualifies you that was
that's been the big issue in the federal
shield bill which seemed over this past
Congress to make its most the greatest
progress that ever has but then I think
that the WikiLeaks situation seems to
have pushed that back and
I think it's unlikely we'll see anything
come out of the rest of this Congress
but it really comes down to that
question which is who is a journalist
and there isn't agreement on that is it
who you work for do you work for a
newspaper or television stations that
make you a journalist many people would
say that that that that enshrines a view
of journalism institutions that's no
longer accurate Politico what are they
there are there an online newspaper or
you know even we do a lot of work with
small investigative nonprofits that are
three or four person shops where
investigative reporters have decided to
band together to work through online
medium they're clearly engaging in
journalism so it's very hard to come up
with a definition that institutional
definition that works and in my view a
functional definition that looks at what
whether the activities look like
journalism to me is the best approach
there was one blogger who went to jail
for refusing to wolf right so I want to
say a bit about his case I mean sure
what was the upshot well the upshot was
is he spent a long time in jail and but
most of the journalism organizations
really rallied around Josh he was he was
a video blogger who was recording the
protests in San Francisco for one of the
g8 summits this was God had been maybe
five or eight years ago and California
has a shield law and the local
prosecutors subpoenaed outtakes that he
didn't make available on his blog and
one of those outtakes they believed
showed some protes um of the protesters
letting fly or damaging a police car and
so they couldn't get the information
from him because he was protected by
California shield law which was a pretty
pretty expansive definition of who's
covered so they so federal prosecutors
came in involved and they said that
because federal money was used to
purchase the police car the local police
had used federal money in part to
purchase a police car it was therefore a
federal issue and federal prosecutors
subpoenaed the information he refused to
turn it over and and he spent several
months in jail at the one point I think
was the longest-serving journalist ever
serve for refusing to turn over
information on a subpoena eventually he
made the information available through
his website not directly in response to
the subpoena but he uploaded the
outtakes which actually is is a lot of
news organizations are starting to do
that a lot of video broadcast journalism
can can now they can upload the outtakes
and avoid the subpoena issue he did that
and he was eventually released but he I
think if not the longest one of the
longest serving journalists and and that
was really a call to arms for a federal
shield law which so even if you practice
journalism in a state that has a shield
law that state shield law isn't going to
prevent a federal prosecutor from from
coming after you for for information
similarly wouldn't protect you in a
civil case in the federal court as well
so two things one when I worked for a
media organization what was routine
practice was you you put up whatever
information that you're using and then
you tape over everything else so you
can't get subpoenaed and I'm sure that's
probably fair you know this was fairly
common practice across 15 or 20 TV
stations across the country I'm sure
that's pretty common through TV networks
generally this kind of practice may
spread because you know because you can
go after citizen journalists and that
way the other thing and I don't want to
get into this too much because it leads
into deep water that will cause me to
drown but when we're talking about who
is and who is not a journalist it brings
us back to a recent Supreme Court
decision this is the Citizens United
case where you had a activist entity
created a I think was a book wasn't it
it was about a Hillary Clinton it was a
movie thank you thank you there was a
film about what Hillary Clinton and the
question is what is this and what is the
role that they're doing is this is this
journalism is this something else in the
the key question in the in the first
go-round of oral arguments was well does
this mean that the government can
control the publication of books and
that's sort of what that's what caused
the rehearing later on and ultimately
they probably helped trigger the
decision that came out as well so trying
to draw
all that line in a way that comports
with all of our understanding of the
First Amendment is very very very hard
and I don't think anybody has has a
grasp of that yet so I did we call the
last thing you've spoken a lot about
liability but in fact what often seems
to us lay people to be a fearsome
ironclad law that puts people at risk
when they speak isn't that at all and I
don't mean to embarrass David are do but
i noticed reading is his biography
online that at one point in private
practice you would you were vetting
articles for libel of for tabloid
newspaper and and it would be helpful to
hear you talk about the line that you
would walk and giving legal advice to a
journalist so that a certain expression
can take place but doesn't put the
journalism organization at risk sure so
the i would say any I did
pre-publication review for the National
Enquirer for several years that's what
James is referring to and talk about a
interesting client any lawyer who does
that's called pre-publication review
would say there's as much art in it as
there is science I mean every lawyer
first and every journalist wants to get
it right so the first question is is is
everything correct do we have good
sources have we corroborated those
sources have we checked everywhere we
need to check and if you feel strongly
that the information is correct then the
likelihood of first of gal getting a
lawsuit is diminished but your ability
to defend it is very strong but what
lawyers look for not just did we get it
right because people sue even when you
get the story right it's how quickly can
my get my client out of the case and
that often turns on privileges things
like if you're reporting on court cases
being able to I'm getting a bit deep in
the details here but you asked that you
know if we're reporting on court cases
are we referencing those court cases
sufficiently to be able to claim what's
called a ferry port privilege
if not let's do it the right way how
many sources do we have if we get if we
relying on anonymous sources we know the
infant we believe the information is
right are we willing to out those
sources to defend ourselves in a libel
case many times the answer that is no
okay well can we get other information
we can defend ourselves with so so its
first of all can it is it factually
correct second can we be in a defensible
position in litigation then the third is
really what kind of a plaintiff could
there be in this case are they someone
who's likely to sue are they a public
figure or are they a private individual
because that has a big difference in the
degree of fault that's imposed on a on a
publisher actual malice is the highest
level of protection for fault that the
defendant would want to have in a libel
case that's for public figures and
public officials for private individuals
they only have to prove negligence which
is a much lower burden so what type of a
plaintiff are they it ends up being a
fairly complicated calculus which is why
i said it's often times as much art as
it is science and it's an area where i
advise folks that if you're engaging in
certain types of online publishing
activities and especially if you're
doing investigative journalism that and
the reason why i said this project i
started at harvard was about trying to
get folks that legal help they need to
find we have a bunch of pre-publication
lawyers around the country who want to
work for small independent journalism
organizations that are doing good
journalism and help them to reduce their
legal risks and so we have propelled
lawyers that can do that work for free
depending on the size of the
organization and also I think it
behooves everyone to be familiar with
libel law to understand where the red
flags are it's a great organization out
of the Poynter Institute for Media
Studies down in st. Petersburg Florida
that runs news university it's a suite
of free self-directed training modules
that cover everything from you know how
to write a lead in a news story through
to defamation copyright and privacy and
i'm doing a module for them that's going
to be coming out in December around news
gathering liability how you can avoid
getting in trouble when you're actually
going out and using recording device
doing interviews those kinds of things
so there's a lot of tools and
educational materials out there to
educate yourself because in the end this
is the best tool you have is your brain
and the more you can pack in there the
better off you're going to be just a
quick aside I was an editor at the
nation magazine for many years and it
was actually often vary a lot of fun to
bat go to bat against the
pre-publication lawyer that we use there
I always thought that that that this was
her lawyers who were really frustrated
editors because you get to rewrite the
story well if you just change the word
from you know you just changed this word
and change that word we can defend it
the ballet between the the the editor
and the lawyers so let's let's go to
another question we I so somebody back
there with go yeah sorry hi I'll get to
you you're standing you wait well I was
just gonna I'm Jim parity I'm with
comparative Media Studies I was just
going to ask questions somebody refer to
WikiLeaks and I'm sure that's you know a
huge elephant someplace and nobody
really wants to get too far into it but
I'm wondering about the people who are
actually using the data from WikiLeaks
bloggers people like that and the impact
of that on them and also what you
foresee is the impact in legislation
things of that sort that events like
this might have it's an excellent
question Daniel Daniel you'll have been
distracted okay so subsequent users
downstream users of the WikiLeaks data
and what we'll use the Iraq in
Afghanistan data data set as an example
generally speaking the First Amendment
would not permit liability for the
republication of that information there
are supreme court cases that have said
that in the context of intercepted cell
phone conversations in Florida that
resulted in a case they went all at the
Supreme Court called Bart Nikki where
the court said you could not hold
these were actual journalism
organizations but you can't hold the
subsequent publisher who didn't have a
role in the initial wrongful conduct
that they didn't do the recording
someone else did provided to them they
simply published it the Pentagon Papers
is a famous case the Daniel Daniel
Ellsberg turned those papers over to the
new york times in the washington post
and he violated his obligations to the
government in keeping that information
secret they then published it and the
court said you cannot enjoin them from
publishing that information they did not
they not they were not the ones who
breached so as you move further away
from the individual who actually engaged
in the improper conduct the ability to
impose legal liability on subsequent
publishers diminishes dramatically I
started by saying downstream publishers
from WikiLeaks because it's not entirely
clear what WikiLeaks his role was in the
initial disclosure of that information
we don't know we don't know how they got
the information in the first place and
so it'd be premature to say whether they
may face liability there is a Espionage
Act that there's been some debate among
lawyers as to whether or not that would
criminalize that would potentially
criminalize an entity like WikiLeaks
it's very the thing which is quite broad
and it probably would fall they probably
would face potential liability under the
Espionage Act the question would then be
whether the First Amendment if the case
were brought in the US whether the First
Amendment would provide any protections
along the lines of what I said with the
bar Nicki case and others so we don't
know so far the government hasn't gone
after them for that and and I think we
may see that case come so similar but
not the same there are a series of very
weak whistleblower laws that are
currently in effect on the federal level
the practical impact of them is that
you're going to lose your job you're
probably not going to get compensation
no good deed will be unpunished which is
unfortunate but that's sort of the way
it is and the project and government
oversight has been working hard to get a
stronger whistle whistleblower
protections now it doesn't fight
fit within the the WikiLeaks model that
we're talking about nor would it fit you
know with Dan Ellsberg but it's the same
that you know that same kind of thing
that's very difficult for people to come
out and ensure the kinds of information
that would be useful and Congress's
reaction to the wikileaks thing and the
transparency community's reaction has
been one of a bit horror actually all
the transparency or almost all the
transparency organizations that I'm
aware of say that this hurts their
ability to advocate for sensible rules
around when this kind of information can
be made publicly available and it hurts
arguments about declassifying and
otherwise making available government
information particularly trying to push
on the DoD even when it's clear that
there's a lot of information that's
either being withheld or being cast in a
light that doesn't necessarily reflect
the reality of what's going on so it
makes the political climate a lot more
difficult to do these kinds of things
you know irresponsible journalism is
going to need to be protected but it
also needs to be condemned when it's
when it's when it's done in this kind of
way and that's about as far as I can go
so I get a add a comment because I
actually disagree you know leaks happen
every day in Washington secret
information is is just it's out there
all the time its authorized leaks
straight from the top when they do it
it's okay no one's prosecuted it's just
the currency of information there and
then they're just a handful of cases
they've only been I think four or five
leakers of government information who
have ever been prosecuted and the Obama
administration is I think currently
responsible for two or three of those
prosecutions they are cracking down
harder on leaking of government
information than any previous
administration go figure now that may be
because they are trying to send the
signal
two would be leakers to WikiLeaks
WikiLeaks is a transnational
organization that is not subject to US
law it's true that anyone associated
with them is probably not going to visit
the United States again we were going to
have Julian Assange and Daniel Ellsberg
meet face-to-face at the conference I
run in New York personal democracy forum
and at the last minute Assange said I
can't come I've been advised that it
wouldn't be safe for me to try and go to
the unite and he had just been to the
United States like three months earlier
so there's something funky going on
around this kind of stuff I'm much more
of a free speech absolutist here than
Daniel it's okay to disagree though but
given how much leaking is just de facto
done and there the laws against it are
pretty vague with the exception of the
Espionage Act and then there's a feature
of the communications some communication
secrecy act that pertains to very
specific types of signal intelligence
that you can't reveal that came up in a
case where you know we had a submarine
that was picking up information off some
cable off the coast of Russia or
something right which in any event we're
getting right into the weeds now yeah go
ahead danger so one thing with leaking
information it's very helpful to be
clever about who you leaked to and how
you get that information out so for
example if you give it to Congress and
there are rules against doing that kind
of thing now Congress of course has the
right to access classified information
they have the right to do all these
kinds of things rights they rarely
exercise rights that they have
nonetheless but if you go to them anyway
oftentimes they can shield you under a
separate provision of the Constitution
the Speech and Debate clause where they
can go this is what they're doing with
Dan Ellsberg where senator gravelle
started reading the Pentagon Papers into
the record in
he cheered some random committee at the
time was like environment or some but
didn't matter he he alternately read it
into the record and broke down crying
into this for like six or eight hours
that is a way of trying to protect
yourself and get this information out
also you can talk to the IG as a way of
trying you know it when the aiji's are
required to report in certain ways you
can use that as a way of getting the
information out unfortunately for most
people these options don't you know
aren't really available to them or
aren't you know the can't can't be
assailed you know can't be made
available so you know there are ways to
do it but there's not enough and it's
not protected in ways that are that are
appropriately useful this is where we
get back to the reporter shield law and
things like that yeah so okay you've
been patient first of all thanks for
thanks for doing this I think this is
great work obviously I'm Joe spur I just
this week was hired by WBUR to direct a
project called order in the court two
point oh and it's all of this happening
right now we're basically charged me
with finding finding the line between
free speech rights and the right to a
fair trial we basically basically have
been given full full access and full
permission from a court in Quincy to
modernize their court stream live blog
citizen journalism whatever so it's an
incredibly exciting but it's also I feel
compelled to ask in the current legal
environment what should we be careful of
it seems like a little bit of a
minefield and the hope is to find that
proper line between free speech rights
and free trial rights and if we do it
right we can create a model for other
courts around the country who want to do
that and we should but yeah just on the
same same subject of experimentation and
deal-making that david had mentioned i
thought it was it was relevant to
right that's that's a great question
Joan say hi to john forming by well this
is a fabulous experiment and i probably
should have mentioned it before because
generally speaking the courts are as i
mentioned earlier presume to be open to
the public but in fact very few people
actually go to a courthouse and ever see
a trial and yet the courts could let
cameras in and they don't and so that
sort of happens out there and we don't
know about it and actually when you talk
to a lot of judges they want the public
to know more of what they're doing
because they're a really central
institution in our society and but you
hit on the i think the real pressure
point in this and that is the public's
the right of access versus the right to
a fair trial and judges of trying to
balance that forever we deal with a lot
of folks who have been for example
excluded from courtrooms for live
blogging or tweeting from court and it's
just a matter of explaining to the judge
what the technology really does and that
it you know it's the same as they old
days they would walk out during a break
it on the phone call to editor read the
story over and it would run in fact a
lot of those organizations still do that
and then it you know goes up on their
website you know the judge needs to
instruct the jurors to to not read the
information judges have a lot of power
including all the way to sequestration
where they can have the jurors stay in a
hotel local to the courthouse not get
any media at all control their meals the
whole deal that's pretty extreme but
there's lots of you know instructions
and things that can be used to balance
that I think the the the bigger point is
is is that as we begin to look at how
these technologies can facilitate access
into courtrooms that that we do so in a
way that doesn't impact the way the the
courtrooms function themselves and one
of the big effects when I'd say the neg
most negative effect two I'm interested
if you to agree with me that slowed down
cameras in the courtroom was eoj Simpson
trial which a lot of people believe
created grandstanding and other
activities that would not have happened
if there weren't cameras in the
courtroom and that really I think was a
setback so it's a way of doing it in a
way
that respects the process I know one of
the things you guys are thinking about
is just a raw data of what goes on the
court the dockets the cases that are
going to be heard make those available
online so that if you have an interest
in the case or it's your neighbor or
whatever you can go that seems to me to
be the most the most logical way to
implement this have very little effect
on the courtroom behavior itself but as
you get to actually streaming live the
the court activities themselves to have
that be done in a conversation with the
lawyers with the judge with the courts
personnel in a way that attempts to make
the technology as unobtrusive as
possible those conversations when we
plan to continue definitely doing that
but it'll be definitely interesting
moving forward a special if we set
something up to transcribe what's
actually happening so you know if your
name is in there and someone Google's
your name it's going to pop right up and
that's a completely new world yep so
there have been a number of attempts to
deal with this both on the state and on
the federal level on the federal over
there has been Ferg's actually with
state level in New Jersey where they
made the entire corpus of local court
decisions available online but there are
problems when you you have instances of
stalking for example where you don't
want to have a person who is identified
where they happen to live or something
on those lines and that kind of
information will get pulled out from
being online if you look at federal
records there's there's pacer which is a
repository of orders and opinions and
things along those lines that's
nominally publicly available and there's
been efforts to make that available at
no cost but want the consequences of
that effort is that courts do a very
poor job of redacted personal
information they don't redact Social
Security numbers the way that's supposed
to didn't react information about minor
children things like that on the way
that they're supposed to and a person
who's been dealing with this a lot is
Carl maalmood in Steven Scholesy who are
going through and building ways of
searching out these particular pieces of
information and yanking them out of
court documents that the courts should
have taken out in the first
and then you also see for example with
the Supreme Court there's ongoing
balancing questions of when do you make
audio from oral arguments available for
a long time it's been that you have to
go to the National Archives and get them
at the end of the term now the cord is
making them available at the end of each
week but of course by making it
available at the end of the week it
doesn't fit into the new cycle when
people would actually want to learn
about what's going on so there's all
sorts of very interesting balancing
questions about these kinds of things I
mean would you want to ear error you
know voir dire online I mean that seems
you know like that's something that you
probably would not want to do because of
the personal questions that are involved
for the jurors so there's there's a
whole bunch of very interesting
questions I'm looking forward to
watching what you're doing so thank you
so okay we have time for a few more
questions I think yeah Joe Haven crosman
retired web developer beyond local
transit information are their
programming interfaces to other public
data that you know of or pushes for the
same I'm going to take that one so so
there's a project called open 311 and I
mean basically what's what's starting to
happen is a couple of cities notably
Washington DC and San Francisco are at
the forefront of this movement to open
municipal data in structured form 311
being the sort of complaint systems that
they now have for taking in public
questions and complaints and and then
processing them and the goal is to get
the information out in a common
structured format so what you want to do
is just look up open 311 and go to the
wiki page and you will see a great deal
of already compiled lists of databases
open 311 is spawning another project
called the Civic Commons project and the
idea there is to really build out a
stack for developers so that if you're
going to build you know
a mobile app for bus you know when is my
bus coming you don't have to design a
new one for each city that they will all
be working off similarly structured data
and it's very exciting I mean this is a
movement that's spreading rapidly around
the world and it's one of those I like
to call this we government it's not
egovernment right you government being
the way the government shares
information or maybe makes it easy for
you to file your taxes or we government
is people using public data and
generating their own data and creating
services on top of it that have a
quasi-governmental role and in some
cases you have the city playing you know
city officials are playing along with
developers because they're beginning to
learn that this is a way to get value
for free or at low cost today of a
iphone app called research which uses
New York City public information yeah
there's a the Park Service's I think
they've mapped every tree there's a
there's one called trees trees near me
or something like that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah no it's a very exciting time
if you're if you're playing in this
space of sort of hacking the city to
play with the this kind of public data
it's actually you know I mean there are
different levels of government and it
seems that the city is the one that
people feel they can reach out and touch
and manipulate in in a more real way
than say your federal government or your
you know the State Capitol this is I
think that if we want to really impact
government transparency is to think
along the lines of the way make it just
described it that the traditional way
that access to government information
has worked is that the onus is on the
person who wants the information to
request it from the government and the
government decides whether to make it
available and under the prior
administration the Attorney General sent
a directive out to all federal agencies
and said your presumption should be not
to disclose
if you can find any reason not to
disclose hold the information and don't
make it available one the first things
President Obama did was issue a
directive that suggests the opposite of
that but there's an institution there's
a culture within government and I met
its it exists from the local level all
the way up that that really is in that
mindset but we need to do is shift the
paradigm which is the default should be
the government make data available it
should be able to default should be all
government information we made available
and there should be categories of
information that are not made available
obviously not everything should should
be made available but we should start
with that default and slowly I think we
would change the culture but cities you
know I realizing that it's a lot nicer
to live in the place if you share this
information and let people build on top
of it and do great things I mean it's it
really has a quality of life impact and
cities and municipalities are starting
to realize that but I think it's a
cultural shift as much as anything else
and I would love to see in Daniels group
that's Sunlight Foundation does so much
great work in this area the dip tube
that they're pushing to make that the
default i think if we can accomplish
that then we'll really have effectuated
significant change questions or comments
yeah again over here
thank you on some sensitive topics that
have explosive growth now and then
talking about our ability to have clean
water clean air only occasionally will
you see how many towns not on this
nation but even in this state that have
made a sea change in the last 10 years I
used to work for the City Planning
Department in a city nearby and also was
the recording secretary so I heard a lot
of the lot of stuff is not written down
a lot of stuff is discussions and deals
and arrangements and a lot of that works
to come to come compromise but when
you're talking about real essentials of
life like quality of water and not just
better quality water but non-toxic now
Boston had a recent temporary problem
few months ago and it and it was it was
solved in a respect to your account was
lowered rather quickly at least six
other towns have had that problem and it
is even in rich towns like Weston of
course that was very well publicized
with the big ten foot circle connecting
link busted and then they were able to
technically fix it within a number of
days weeks but what I'm talking about is
the what you just taught that what
you're saying now is the availability of
that information to the citizenry while
those towns are thinking about it
there's pregnant women there's infants
there's a lot of other people how can we
balance and include some of these
current things that be citizenry she
needs to know but for their health and
also help influence their decision
making process on maybe we should really
double think about this now over
development that's happening the
wetlands acts and stuff are being
cremated developments happening in the
last five to six years to a huge extent
and it's a direct the people that have
been protecting it they know it's not
just about saving turtles they know it's
about the quality of the actual Eric for
humans and stuff too and water so so
let me address at least part of that and
this goes to there was a recent Pew
study which talks about how people get
information and it talks about how do
you reach more people where they live
how do you get their attention you know
it used to be you go through the local
news you go through the local news but
you know TV news or newspapers and
things like that and many city
governments are now not surprising to
people in this room are going online and
they're not it's not just pull you know
it's not just pull its push so it's you
know for let me give you a good example
I follow the city of Alexandria which is
where I live so when there is a water
main break in town like there was last
week I know about it when there's
something when there's a farmers market
in town I know about it when I want to
communicate or Twitter this is through
Facebook actually it's through facebook
but you can do the same thing through
Twitter you can do the same thing
through a number of other sites you also
see every block doing things like that
there are ways that you can report
potholes if you take out your phone and
you were writing about this you click
fix see click fix in an excellent op-ed
in the Wall Street Journal was right
yeah so there are those kinds of ways
that people are using these kinds of
media to figure out what's going on in
the government to communicate with them
one sort of very interesting model that
we've seen actually comes out of the UK
and it involves their equivalent of FOIA
where there is a website called what do
they know and they act as an
intermediary between people who have the
equivalent of FOIA requests in the
government and what they do is they look
at the FOIA request they say is this
something that has been asked before or
is it not if it's something that is new
they figure out the appropriate agency
within the government they forward it on
to them they get the response back and
they give it to the citizen they also
post the response online so that when
other people have the same question they
can find answers that you know so it
decreases the burden on government it
puts more information available online
it's an incredibly useful kind of
service where you know sort of third
parties are acting as an intermediary
know there are other instances where
this kind
behavior either can be mediated through
third parties or where the government
itself can sort of step into this role
of trying to help basically acting as a
concierge acting as a way of directing
information to the right kind of place
making available to people in a useful
kind of way so yeah one thing people
need to know about since again we're at
MIT so I'm assuming the geek level is a
bit higher than for a normal audience so
the reason why what do they know works
is that you can file requests for a
Freedom of Information request
electronically and get back in answer
electronically and so what and this is
all done by an organization called my
society which is probably the world's
premier sort of Civic hackers I mean
they were certainly inspirations for us
when we were setting up sunlight and so
if somebody emails post their question
in the interface that what do they know
has built the question is then sent to
the relevant government agency but first
the email address that it comes from the
site generates a special email address
so that when the response comes back it
comes back to that address and can be
turned into a URL okay so that there is
no person in the room converting the
document it's done already the answer is
there as a web document which makes it
searchable we don't have the same
capability at the federal level because
we don't have the ability to file a FOIA
request electronically I don't know what
the state or the local laws are and it
seems to me that there's plenty of room
here for variation and experimentation
and there may be some states and cities
that want to get ahead of the curve and
say sure yeah you can file
electronically will answer
electronically and then it's a simple
matter of copying the code from what do
you know which I'm sure is open source
yeah a Freedom of Information Act
request I mean that's basically under
the law you have there was all kinds of
public documents that you can ask for
and get but you have to make the request
the point of making these requests
social and searchable is that over time
that information should be out in public
view and you know not for each person
have to repeat we've sunlight is also
tried to fund some work around making
documents that have been made available
through FOIA requests at the federal
level there's a project called open FOIA
which i think is done by crew is that
correct and the theory there is this is
an organization that has sued the White
House a number of times and and other
government agencies and gotten huge
document dumps and they don't have the
ability to sift every document so the
notion there is it's a repository where
people public interest groups in
particular they get these dumps can post
the raw documents and then anybody can
go help filter and tag them so if you
want to go through you know some I'm
trying to remember what some of their
most famous cases they were mostly suing
the Bush administration for information
around Dick Cheney's energy task force
for example so there's a lot of raw sift
able information sitting at open FOIA
the truth is you know we're I mean we're
coming to the close of our conversation
we really should talk about what and I
want to pose this question but it's also
question for all of us we're kind of
sitting on top of this cambrian
explosion of information of
participation and it's it feels to me
like our systems for filtering are way
behind the just the raw flow you know
it's almost like that that the the stuff
spewing up
from the bottom of the Gulf is that's
the information space that we're in
right now and I you know do you agree
deep yeah let's put a cap on it well
maybe the government classification is
certainly a way but i think the the
larger issue is that social media is
also raw information flow i won't call
it sewage or you know spill but I think
our tools for filtering are nowhere
close to what we need as I actually
wanted to propose a mashup just kind of
as a thought it ties right into this i'm
looking at tech president we still don't
know how to vote is the headline and it
talks about people don't know what
they're voting for how why okay
meanwhile you have what do they know and
i'm wondering has anybody thought about
a real-time game of accountability live
accountability imagine a wikipedia
that's built around a live debate
between two politicians and as the
debate is happening people in real time
are resourcing linking and ask or pop
degradative like vh1 pop-ups you
remember Zack some videos so because I
think it has to be fast it has to be as
fast as the spew it's a fantastic idea
and we built it part of it anyway part
of it there's a lot more it's called
sunlight live and we've covered a couple
of events we just covered the election
coverage you know Tuesday night we did
the president's discussion with
Republicans and Democrats around
healthcare the health care bill as well
the six or eight hours of that and what
it was is we took a feed from c-span so
we had a little box of what's going on
that we had contextual information all
around it so when somebody would come
and speak we would put up the
information about who is their donor who
have they voted for we have I
participate as a one of the live
commenter so I would help explain what
was going on along with a numb
of my colleagues it's time and reporting
intensive to get all this information
and data together but we've now done
this a couple of times and it is
incredibly helpful it's it's like c-span
on steroids you know it's all the
context that you could ever hope for and
more you know they mentioned a bill well
there's a link to the bill they
mentioned a report here's the link to
the report here's an explanation of what
they're saying seguin doobies the line
do we flag lies if it flies yes your fat
check look you're watching a
conversation and some tea party member
says the First Amendment protects
churches you say when a big red X comes
up that was okay so what we would do is
we would link to primary sources so that
people could evaluate the information
for themselves if there were things that
were obviously incorrect we would say
here's another place that you can look
or here is you know other points of view
we didn't want to be trying to
fact-check all of that because it would
be impossible to do that particularly in
that environment ride to make it so that
people can make decisions for themselves
about what they chose to believe and
what they didn't believe well I actually
so the sunlight live is is a pretty
clunky mashup of various data streams so
it's dependent on a video feed and if
you don't have the video feed it's it's
a little hard to gather the audience but
you know the theory is that there are
these live events that do naturally
attract people and then you we used a
cover it live tool that which is a live
blogging tool that people can comment in
in addition and we also had pre-loaded a
part of the page where we could swap in
things like the campaign contributions
that each member had gotten and so on we
have recently gotten funding from the
knight Foundation to basically rebuild
the whole sunlight live platform from
scratch and and open-source it so that
it could be used by other entities
journalistic or whatever right and
marked I would say that
if Jimmy Wales was sitting here he would
tell you that uh that often the
Wikipedia page on a breaking news event
is the most authoritative page to go to
and that lots of people will you know
add information and and you know branch
off in different directions so it's
already happening to a certain degree
it's not that a wild an idea that you
just threw out there but I think it's
great that the CNN tracking of the you
know people turning their dials well I
think the media system is I mean the
interesting thing that I'm seeing happen
is that due to competitive pressures I
mean lots of media is now trying to show
off their technological savvy some of it
is kind of silly you know Holograms and
and the like on CNN but but they are
feeling some competitive pressure to be
more interactive to fact check to some
degree so there's there's room here to
push experiments and then hopefully get
some copycat behavior I think your point
Mika though and these tools are starting
to get us there is that data leads to
information information leads to
knowledge knowledge leads to wisdom and
we're sort of at this stage probably
between data and information may be
inching towards information to knowledge
that as we start to use these these I
think crowdsourcing is one of the ways I
mean we're all of us smarter than any
one of us and we can break up these
tasks these time-consuming tasks and
share them around we can actually
benefit from the embedded knowledge in
our communities and we can do it not
just within the u.s. committee we can
start to look outside the US for other
legal approaches for other approaches to
problem solving and we can bring that
information together in a way that
actually moves us from a glut of data to
real knowledge and then hopefully the
wisdom where we can make better
decisions as a society and and we're
moving in that direction it's for me
it's it's I'm optimistic that we're
starting to see this kind of thing and I
wasn't aware of sunlight live but I mean
this is a pretty rudimentary but
powerful idea
that you can only see improving year
after year and I think this is part of
the answer to the question that you just
posed you know there is so much
information out there how do you filter
it how do you deal with it and you start
figuring out what do you trust who is
giving you the things that would lead
you to trusted are they linking to
primary sources is it is it gathered
from all around the world can you figure
out how the different mechanisms and
pieces move we're not there I mean right
now I mean we're all drowning in
information we all probably have
internet phones in our pockets you know
connected 24 7 all that kind of stuff
but it's starting to get to the point
where you figure out ways ways through
the mounds of information was it's going
from information to all you know up to
knowledge up to wisdom you know it is
drawing the wisdom of crowds it is
trying to figure out how do you know
what you what you should know and what
it is that you should know about what
you're learning so well I can actually
both of you have just made great
concluding statements so unless you want
to add to either of them I know we're
just at just about at a time so I'm
going to let it let it let our thoughts
settle on on those optimistic
conclusions which I actually share and
and I do think we are living through
confusing but ultimately exciting times
and and I'm optimistic that we can
navigate our way through the garden of
the ocean of mine fields that we've and
and and find value as we make our way so
thank you you really illuminated a lot
tonight thanks furuta this audience and
we'll hang around we'll keep talking
people want to stay
you